das hier ist ein Nashville hot chicken
Sandwich das habe ich in Kalifornien
lieben gelernt und man kriegt es warum
auch immer nirgendwo in Deutschland
deshalb machen wir es einfach selbst
dafür müssen wir aber erstmal das
regnerische Deutschland verlassen und
uns in das warme Tennessee begeben genau
genommen nach Nashville denn dort wurde
das Nashville hot chicken erfunden dass
die USA im Sturm erobert wir haben
national schicken 2022 in Los Angeles
bei Daves hot chicken entdeckt wir waren
auf dem marrows einfach nur wollten
einfach eine Kleinigkeit essen haben
gesagt oder irgendwie chicken Shop gehen
wir mal rein ab dem Tag war nichts mehr
gleich wir haben wirklich in den
nächsten Tagen fast täglich dort
gegessen ich weiß nicht was es ist
einfach so dieser Schärfe Kick mit dem
perfekten fried chicken in einem
Sandwich zusammen das hat irgendeine
nervt getroffen von dem ich gar nicht
wusste dass ich ihn habe und ich glaube
so geht es vielen von euch auch in
Deutschland suchst du das ganze wirklich
vergebens und ich brauche es jetzt
einfach wieder in den letzten Jahren
waren Smash Burger das große Ding und
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass nashion
hat schicken als nächstes dran deshalb
entdecken wir es gemeinsam und beginnen
mit der ersten Zutat mit dem Coleslaw
bzw unser Cales law Cole das ist cool
und Kale das ist cool ich weiß nicht
genau wie die sich auf Deutsch
unterscheiden aber ihr seht ja den
Unterschied diese beiden Sorten Kohle
kommen in unseren call slow rein denn
der wird es in sich haben beginnen wir
mit einer Mandoline fangen wir mit der
Zwiebel an die Mandoline geht auf die
feinste Stufe und wir ziehen die hier
einfach ein paar Mal durch ich sage euch
Leute dieses Ding ist einfach
unerlässlich wir haben wunderschöne
feine Streifen von unserer roten Zwiebel
die vor allem fürs Auge sind aber auch
so ein bisschen so eine kleine Schärfe
mit reingeben wir machen weiter mit
unserem Weißkohl den Viertel ich einmal
so können wir ihn auch schön durch
unsere Mandoline ziehen das ist wirklich
übrigens auch notwendig man kann nicht
einfach einen fertigen Salat kaufen weil
der ist immer viel zu süß und so wir
wollen diesen besonderen Geschmack es
kann ruhig zu unseren Zwiebeln dazu am
Ende kommt eh alles zusammen guckt euch
das an so fein soll es sein reimt sich
sogar da muss es stimmt das gleiche
machen wir mit unserem Grünkohl Wirsing
oder wie auch immer man dieses Ding hier
nennt schaut euch das an feiner grüner
Kohl weißer Kohl und ein paar rote
Zwiebeln was fehlt jetzt noch richtig
dass ich mein Video veröffentlichen wir
haben 14 Uhr ich erfahre mich immer um
14 Uhr meine Videos ein Dressing und das
besteht aus Mayonnaise weißem Essig Senf
und Zucker ich würde einfach alles hier
drin zusammen Zucker drin Apfelessig
folgt und wir gehen mit ein bisschen die
Chanson dran verrühren das ganze jetzt
gebe ich unser dressing über den Kohl
drüber das muss richtig schwimmen gleich
am Ende zwei Sachen dürfen natürlich
nicht fehlen einmal Salz und die Prise
und Pfeffer leute das ist erst der
Anfang aber es lohnt sich wirklich dran
zu bleiben weil was wir am Ende in der
Hand haben werden davon träume ich schon
seit einiger Zeit und ordentlich ein
massiert lasst euch da auch wirklich
Zeit das wirklich alles miteinander gut
verbunden ist also Leute so lassen wir
das mindestens für eine Stunde ziehen
und dann ist unser Code noch Kales
fertig was könnte beim national schicken
noch wichtig sein richtig das Chicken
das habe ich hier vor mir ihr kennt mich
mittlerweile schicken Koteletts also
quasi Hähnchenschenkel ausgelöst vom
Knochen sind meine Nummer eins es könnte
natürlich auch tenders das heißt
Brustfilet benutzen aber ich sage euch
ehrlich das hier ist saftiger günstiger
und insgesamt einfach krasser dazu
machen wir eine kleine Marinade ganz
wichtig es muss in Buttermilch mariniert
sein gebe ich einmal hier in die
Schüssel hinein dann hat schicken
brauchen wir natürlich auch hotshots
Leute wichtig die Schärfe kommt nicht
nur durch den dust am Ende oder durch
ein scharfes Öl nein wir haben in jedem
Element wirklich Schärfe drin die auch
tief einziehen kann in unser Fleisch
denn das ist das Wichtigste das ist
wirklich schön spicy ist und dadurch
schaffen wir es halt nicht nur eine
stupide Schärfe die weh tut auf der
Zunge zu bekommen sondern auch jede
schärfer bringt ja nur außen mit sich
einfach Elemente von Schärfe schienenste
Arten von Schärfe die dann einen
Geschmack auch hervorrufen dass das hier
ist dann kann ich euch verstehen denn
man weiß es nicht genau das ist
Gurkenwasser einfach von eingelegten
Gurken ein bisschen Wasser das dann
Zucker drin Essig drin Wasser drin
wichtig für den Geschmack wichtig für
die Marinade und zu guter Letzt ein Ei
da war ich mir auch nicht ganz sicher
aber das ist Teil des Rezepts man macht
einfach ein Ei mit in die Marinade
verquirlen das ganze wir kennen schon
eine schöne Farbe diese leicht orange
Färbung da weiß man da steckt Geschmack
drin nehmen wir also unser chicken legen
es hier in unsere Buttermilch hinein
gucken dass es wirklich von allen Seiten
schön bedeckt ist und auch bedeckt
bleibt und dann geht es für mindestens
24 Stunden in den Kühlschrank den sagen
wir mindestens zwei Stunden aber wir
lassen 24 Stunden drin weil wir wollen
dass es wirklich wirklich gut wird
unsere letzte auf Zutat ist nicht zu
unterschätzen und das handelt sich um
die gute alte Gewürzgurke und ich werde
sie heute endlich zum allerersten Mal in
meinem Leben selbst machen wir haben ihm
gefällt indem wir sie einlegen können
etwas Essig natürlich unsere Gurken
Senfkörner Zucker die Knoblauch es ist
wirklich einfach es dauert halt nur ein
bisschen wir nehmen unseren Essig es
sind 300 Milliliter schütten wir auf 500
ml Wasser Zucker 30 Gramm das ganze
lassen wir einmal aufkochen und rühren
dabei bist der Zucker einmal komplett
aufgelöst ist der Zucker ist aufgelöst
und unsere Gurken bereit mir vor indem
wir sie einfach terrassenstein die so
ein bisschen zu groß für unser Gefäß das
heißt und ein bisschen was ab um ein
bisschen was ab und dann sollte das
ganze auch schon passen wie angegossen
ab jetzt geben wir unsere Senfkörner
rein können wir einfach dazu schütten
die schwimmen gleich sowieso hoch eine
Knoblauchzehe man kann hier wirklich
rein werfen was man will um es zu
aromatisieren und wir stopfen noch
unseren Dill hinterher jetzt gebe ich
einmal noch die Enden so mit an die
Seite jetzt übergießen wir das ganze mit
Essig Wasser und Zucker jetzt schließen
wir das Ganze für eine Woche sieht es
nicht geil aus es wird Zeit für ich sage
immer das ist ein wichtiges Bestandteil
ist aber es sind auch alle Bestandteile
verdammt wichtig wir machen
einmal
und zwar mit wenigen Zutaten aber hier
machen wir alles selbst damit wir
wirklich den Homepage Stempel bekommen
und es ist auch verdammt einfach wichtig
natürlich für den mario ist in Adobe die
gibt's bei mir im asiatischen Supermarkt
der auch eine kleine Sparte für
mexikanische Produkte hat davon nehme
ich einfach mal so die Hälfte weniger
das riechen könnte leute das ist so
rauchig und so intensiv der Geruch jetzt
ein Esslöffel und damit das Ganze bindet
ein Ei eine Prise Salz dazu ihr solltet
mittlerweile wissen wo sie Salzburg gibt
und wir müssen das Ganze einmal durch
von unten nach oben langsam hochziehen
guckt euch das an die ist richtig schön
dickflüssig tropft langsam von unserem
Löffel und ich probiere einmal
gehen wir also noch mal eine ordentliche
Ecke Honig dran die Süße hat ein
bisschen gefehlt
süß rauchig cremig so muss das sein
dieses chicken ist 24 Stunden mariniert
das ist richtig zart und lecker wird wir
haben vorhin noch mal extra Bett gemacht
der ist für morgen denn man kann das
ohne Probleme auf zwei Tage in Folge
Essen eine Sache ist wirklich
entscheidend und zwar der das Drop bzw
die Mischung von Gewürzen und dieser
kleine Kollege hier dominiert das hier
ist Cayennepfeffer Cayennepfeffer ist
wirklich scharf und wir haben eine Menge
davon denn wir werden in drei
verschiedenen Etappen diese
Gewürzmischung an unserer chicken
bringen zum einen wenn wir es panieren
dann werden wir es später mit einer
Ölmischung bestreichen und zum Schluss
noch mal berieseln Leute das wird krass
keine Zeit verlieren Cayennepfeffer Salz
geräucherte Paprika und wir eigentlich
immer wenn man amerikanisch kocht
Knoblauchpulver und Zwiebelpulver sieht
zwar nicht viel aus aber das Zeug hier
hat es endlich das ist wirklich purer
Geschmack wir geben ein bisschen davon
zu unserer Panade ein bisschen davon in
eine weitere Schüssel und dazu ein
bisschen Rohrzucker das hier wird unser
Lack mit dem wir das Chicken später
bestreichen nachdem ich frittiert wurde
und der wird jetzt perfekt indem wir
darauf heißt es Öl Gießen also Friteuse
ist schon heiß 180 Grad hat das Öl nehme
mir eine Kelle von unserem Frittieröl
und schütte das einfach einmal oben
drauf
das ist krass Digger alter das ist auch
so eine Technik die habe ich sonst noch
nirgendwo gesehen drei Schritte zum
perfekten Nashville hot chicken
zuallererst einmal panieren mit flavours
in der Panade zweitens lackieren mit
unserem Lack und zum Schluss Tasten mit
unserem Pulver Leute
genug geredet genug vorbereitet panieren
wir das verdammte chicken nehmen wir
unser mariniertes checken legen es in
die Panade bedecken ist gleichmäßig ein
bisschen Geduld sollte es dann so
aussehen wir sehen auch schon so diese
kleinen Flocken kriegen jetzt auf die
große Reise in die Fritteuse
[Musik]
wollen wirklich diese goldbraune Farbe
haben aber das wird krass und Freunde
unser chicken ist wirklich perfekt durch
frittiert und während es jetzt noch heiß
ist nehmen wir uns unseren Pinsel und
Pinseln ordentlich von unserer Nashville
source drüber und direkt darauf folgt
noch mal ein bisschen von unserem dust
jetzt auch durch das Öl dann direkt so
hydriert wird noch mal ein dunkle Farbe
bekommt von beiden Seiten natürlich
kannst du dir vorstellen gleich ja mann
wir lassen das Ganze ein bisschen
abkühlen also kümmern wir uns um das
Bahn nimmt die Auswahl vom Bahnhof auf
jeden Fall nicht auf die leichte
Schulter das sind drei verschiedene die
alle unterschiedlich weich sind und
vertraut mir wenn ich euch sage nehmt
das weiches sind das ist jetzt vom Rewe
das ist zum französischen Namen die
Bäckerei das hier ist die Marke Brioche
von Tunnel und genau keine Ahnung
Französisch und das Posten
Preis frittiert ja auch wirklich sehr
schön knusprig sind auch mal mit der
gleichen Gewürzmischung gedacht und
jetzt richten wir an zunächst ein
bisschen
von unserem selbstgemachten poolsalat
nicht zu viele allerdings dann folgen
die Pickels drei Stück und jetzt und das
darf und soll gerne genauso gigantisch
groß sein wie es ist unser chicken guckt
euch das an das Band ist einfach
verschwunden
[Musik]
jetzt kommt unsere Soße dran und die
legen wir so komplett von links nach
rechts drüber Gründen wir das ganze mit
unserem verschwinden kleinen Deckel
es kam mir doch keiner sagen dass wir
gerade in Deutschland sind und nicht in
Kalifornien der Moment auf den wir alle
gewartet haben Nashville hat chicken
Sandwich guckt euch das einfach an das
Band genau wie es sein sollte
verschwindet einfach in meinen Händen
wir haben die Soße obendrauf ihr habt ja
gesehen wie wir zusammengebaut haben wir
jetzt einfach nur noch ein guten Appetit
das ist so krank das ist wirklich egal
das ist nur noch so Papier dünn es ist
wirklich geisteskrank Geschmacks Schärfe
ist wirklich wirklich das was den Nagel
auf dem Kopf trifft weil es tut ganz weh
tut überhaupt nicht weh aber du hast
wirklich so viele Dimensionen von Chili
chipolla normale Chili dann hast du den
cayennepfe das Hähnchen ihr seht es hier
vorne so saftig oh mein Gott bist du
gerade oder in Deutschland
einfach an das ist zu krass das zu krass
was ich immer so auf auf Instagram und
so dass Leute das so essen aber
so groß
aufhören zu filmen ich will jetzt hier
ich will so mit meinem Gesicht so hier
reingehen Leute auch wenn das vielleicht
nicht völlig ist nehmt vielleicht aus
dem Video mit wenn ihr Bock auf
irgendwas habt und egal wo ihr es
gegessen habt ob es Philippinen waren ob
es in Amerika war oder von Duras keine
Ahnung könnte es euch einfach selbst
zubereiten weil das hier gibt's so nicht
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video wieder
ich gehe meine Hände waschen nachdem ich
das hier alles aufgegessen habe bis
dahin macht's gut und Tschüss family ist
auch ne
die White Gang ich
[Musik]
40 10 km